- [Derek] So, hi everyone.
Welcome to "Accelerate
Multi-step SDLC with Kiro."
Glad to have you here.
My name's Derek and with me is Kiran,
and we both work on
the Developer Agents and
Experiences Team at AWS.
We've both been on the team
for the last year or so.
It's a really exciting
time to be in the space.
We work with our agentic
software development products,
including Kiro, and then
customers all around the world
who are using these products
to develop software.
Our team is former software developers
that are now engaged with
other software developers
around the world that are
adopting these products.
I'm curious, show of hands,
who in the room is a software
developer by profession?
Okay, yeah, at least maybe half, okay.
Who's vibe coded?
Who's vibe coded before?
Okay, some of the same
hands, some other hands.
Vibe coding is obviously a hot topic,
using AI to generate code.
These tools are getting better
and better all the time.
And I think vibe coding is a great start,
but the conversation we're
having a lot with customers is
beyond using AI to do the build step,
how do I use AI at every step
in the software development lifecycle,
and not just the build step.
So that's the purpose of the talk today.
And this is a coding session,
so I'm gonna do a little
bit of talking up front.
Try not to do too much.
But I just wanna set the
stage for a few things here.
So we'll talk about the
software development workflow
that we're gonna use,
with agentic tooling.
And then we're gonna
talk a little bit about
how we compose agents,
what they're made up of,
how the agentic loop works,
and how we can configure them in Kiro CLI.
Very important step, before
we go into actually using AI
for software development workflow.
So we'll do that up front,
and then as quickly as I can,
I'll hand over to Kiran who's gonna do
a bunch of live coding today.
But we're not just gonna write code,
we're gonna start at the
beginning of the SDLC.
We're gonna do requirements,
we're gonna do system design,
we're gonna make some decisions,
and eventually we'll write some code
and hopefully we'll have
a working game to play
by the end of the session here.
Live coding, live AI codings,
always gonna be a fun time.
So just to level set, I think
any of us could draw a picture
of the software development lifecycle,
and there's lots of different
ways we could express it.
And if you ask different folks,
they'll have different opinions about
which steps there should be
and which order they should be in,
and how fast you iterate
on the different steps.
But broadly speaking, we
need to have requirements.
We need to do a system
design, we need to plan,
we need to build, we need
to test, we need to package,
and then we need to deploy and operate.
And when we talk about
vibe coding, in my opinion,
we're really talking about
skipping to the right code step.
Which can be great for prototyping
or for trying something out,
or maybe just scratching
a itch in a language
that you don't know or something.
But when it's time to actually do
professional software development,
we don't wanna skip steps.
And so the question
becomes, how can we use AI
for all of these steps?
There are a few approaches for this.
We've got two Kiro products
now, we've got the Kiro IDE,
which just went into GA
in the last month or so.
And then we also have the Kiro CLI,
which we'll be using today.
The approach that we're gonna use
for the live coding session,
you could use in Kiro IDE or Kiro CLI.
This is really a preference thing
in terms of the user
experience that you like.
Kiran and I are both
a bit of console geeks
and so we're gonna invite you all to be
console geeks with us for Kiro CLI today.
So the framework we're
gonna use is called AI-DLC,
and we wanna show one way
that you can approach this.
This is not the only way.
Kiro IDE has spec-driven
development built into it,
and so that's another
way that you can approach
using AI-powered requirements
and system design and planning.
AI-DLC is another way.
It's a little bit more granular
than what you would see in the Kiro IDE.
And this is something that
we've actually open-sourced,
and released on GitHub
in the last week or two.
So we won't go too much
into the details of AI-DLC,
it's gonna be in the background
sort of guiding us along
as we go through the steps.
But we have a slide at the end
that has a QR code and a link.
So if you like what you see
and you'd like to try
out AI-DLC for yourself,
and some of these prompts,
you're welcome to do so,
and we'd love to hear your feedback.
So AI-DLC, roughly speaking,
has this concept of
an inception phase where
we're going through
the requirements and the
design and the planning.
A construction phase,
where we're doing the
building and the packaging.
And then an operation phase.
We're gonna go through the inception
and the construction phase today,
and get hopefully to a working game
by the end of the hour here.
So I wanna spend a few
minutes on agent composition
before we jump into the coding.
So this I think is a
commonly accepted definition
of an agent.
This is Simon Willison's definition.
"An LLM agent runs tools in
a loop to achieve a goal."
Very simple.
The simplicity is what we like.
For today's purposes, I'm
gonna modify that a little bit.
And I'm gonna say, an LLM
agent runs tools in a loop,
while building context, to achieve a goal.
And I'll elaborate on
that in a minute here,
but what we're finding is,
managing the context and the
tools are critically important
to getting the results that we want,
out of this agentic software
development process.
If we skip this step, or
if we don't get it right,
we're not gonna get the
results that we want.
So this becomes an important
step in the workflow
to making sure that our agent
is configured correctly.
So here's a diagram, again,
an agentic loop is nice and simple.
The user, in this case
we're using the Kiro CLI,
we're gonna ask it to
do something as input.
It's gonna take that into its context.
We're gonna pass it to the LLM
to decide what to do about our goal.
The LLM is gonna come back and say,
"I want to take some action using a tool."
We're gonna go call that
tool, whatever it is.
The tool is gonna return a result,
that goes back into the context,
and we go back to the
agent again and we say,
"Okay, we ran the tool.
What would you like to do next?"
We'll keep iterating until
the LLM decides we're done,
and we're ready to give a
response back to the user.
So let's talk about each
of these parts briefly,
starting with LLM.
So for today's purposes,
we are gonna care about applied AI,
and not the gory details
about how LLM works.
So for our purposes today,
I'm not going to try and talk about
the semantic relationships
that are in the model weights,
and n-dimensional vector
space and all that stuff.
I'm sure some of the folks in the room
are experts at this stuff.
What we're gonna say is,
an LLM gives us reasoning.
We could debate the how
it gives us reasoning
or the details, but if we ask
it to reason about something,
it will do that and it will come back,
and come up with an
approach for a problem.
We're also not gonna talk
about auto regression
and multi-head attention
and all that stuff.
What we're gonna say is,
the model has knowledge
embedded into the model weights.
What we would call latent knowledge,
that's been trained into the model
during the pre-training step.
It knows stuff, right?
How it does the recall, we'll
leave for a different session,
but our LLM is gonna give
us the ability to reason,
and it's gonna have latent knowledge.
Facts that it knows about the world.
So that's great, but next
we need working memory,
for the model to be able to
understand what it's doing
and keep track of where we're going.
And that's the context window.
So here's a very simplified
sort of mental model
of the context window.
It's everything that's in the
model's working memory, right?
So starting with system prompts
that are behind the scenes,
guiding the agent's behavior.
Any context files that we've loaded,
we're gonna see example
of that here in a minute.
The history of our chat so far.
So we've opened up our chat window,
we're going back and forth,
working on a problem with the agent.
That's all in the context window.
Any source code that it's
pulled up and looked at,
if we're working on an existing project.
The output of all the tools
that we've called so far.
And then hopefully some free space
so that we can keep going.
And so managing this context window
is extremely important for us
to get the results that we want.
If I'm asking the agent to
work with some custom library
that I've developed,
and it doesn't know anything
about that custom library,
we're gonna get a very different result
than if I were to load up the
documentation for that library
into the context window.
So we wanna make sure that
we get this right upfront.
And then finally for this section,
tool selection and tool execution.
MCP has taken over in
the last six months or so
as the defacto standard
for tool use with agents.
For those of you who aren't familiar,
I think of MCP as the
USB protocol for agents.
I can take a plug, it'll
plug into any agent
and it'll let me plug
skills into the agent
so that it learns how to do something new.
It'll let me give it
access to reading resources
from another location that it needs.
And possibly give it the
ability to take action.
So almost like an API
where it can do a mutative
or make a change on another system.
And so getting the MCP tools right, again,
is another critical piece
of getting ready for us
to go do our agentic software development.
If we need access to Jira,
if we need access to our internal wiki,
if we need access to
go search the internet,
we need to make sure that any
of these tools that we need
are plugged in.
So we talked about the agentic loop
and how having the right
LLM model to do reasoning,
the right context window, content,
in order for it to have
that in its working memory,
what it needs to know.
And we talked about having
the right tools plugged in.
These are all the ingredients
to having the configuration that we need.
So today we're gonna be using Kiro CLI
to do our live coding session.
And in Kiro CLI we have this
concept of a custom agent.
And the custom agent is really a bundle of
all of those things that we can store,
we can share with our teammates,
we can publish internally
if we want other teams
to be able to use it.
We could just save it for ourselves.
But it gives us the ability to
combine our model selection,
what context we want
in the context window.
So system prompt, static
resource files, hooks,
which give us the ability
to do some dynamic context.
And then tools.
Which MCP servers do I want to be using?
Within each MCP server
that could be exposing multiple tools,
which ones do I wanna
allow the agent to use?
Maybe not all of them.
I can alias them if I want
to give them different names.
So all of this goes into one file,
which Kiran will show us here in a minute,
that lets us build our custom agent.
So we're gonna do that first.
Kiran's gonna walk us through
building our custom agent
and then we'll come back briefly
and talk about what we're gonna go build.
So with that.
Kiran, over to you.
- [Kiran] Thanks everyone.
Not sure that's worked yet.
- The joys of a live demo.
- Yeah.
Good fun
Demo.
- I saw a flicker.
- Yeah.
Worked two seconds before
we started as well.
Do you want me to unplug
and plug it again?
Yeah.
There we go.
- Hey, there we go!
- [Kiran] Reboot.
Okay.
All right, so the first
thing, hi everyone.
So the first thing we're gonna do today is
configure the custom agent.
And so you can see exactly
what Derek was talking about
on those slides.
So diving right in, I'm just
gonna go straight into Kiro,
there we go, into the Kiro CLI.
And as Derek mentioned,
we have an IDE that you could use as well,
but for the purposes of this,
we're gonna use the Kiro CLI.
So the first thing we're gonna do, I was,
we're gonna configure our custom agent
before we actually go
ahead and build a game.
So in order to do that,
I'm gonna go agent.
List out the agents that we've got.
So when you first start off,
you have a Kiro default agent
you can see there in green.
And then I've got a Flappy Kiro agent here
that I've built
specifically for this demo.
But if you wanna build your
own, you just go agent, oops.
So it's agent and then it's create.
Give it a name and we're
gonna call this demo agent 1.
Now this is your agent configuration file.
This one's empty, I'll
show you the populated one
in just a second.
But this is where you'll
configure all those things
Derek told you about, your MCP servers,
the tools that your MCP
servers have access to.
And we should have called
out the acronym on first use,
I don't think we did, a
model context protocol.
The tool aliases, as Derek mentioned,
in case you want to give
those a differentiating name.
The tools that your
agents are allowed to use,
and the different resources.
So what we'll do is we'll
quit out of here and show you
what that looks like.
Oops.
Got the prompt saved here.
Thought I had.
There we go.
Wrong one.
There we go, sorry about that.
So for this particular agent,
we've got a couple of
MCP servers configured.
So I've got a Mermaid MCP server,
so that's gonna help us build
diagrams for the requirements
and the business requirements
that we're gonna do,
as well as the implementation plan.
I have a fetch MCP server
to go and fetch things
off the internet for us.
And that's 'cause when we
build the Flappy Kiro game,
I want it to be able to
go and fetch AWS services
from the internet,
and use that instead of a
normal Flappy Bird game,
and make that a little
bit more interesting.
Maybe use a Halloween
and a Vegas type theme.
So I've got some tools that
I've got loaded here as well.
Some faster, some read
and write tools as well.
And the reason for not putting all tools
that the MCP server has access
to is, as Derek mentioned,
you've only got a certain amount of space
in your contacts window.
So you don't wanna overwhelm the agent
with tools that it doesn't need.
So I've locked it down
just for specific tools,
for it to do that with.
And then I've got under the
resources, the AI-DLC workflow.
And as we mentioned, we'll
link that in a QR code
towards the end of the presentation.
But it'll give you a list of
all the different components
of the AI-DLC, all the
different questions and answers
and how it all works throughout there.
So I've told the agent to be
able to access that as well
for the purposes of building this out.
And then hooks, as we mentioned earlier,
that's something for you to,
for the agent to take action on.
So really good for sort of
CI/CD pipeline type things
that you might be doing.
We're not gonna do
anything for that in here.
We're just going to focus
on using the MCP servers
and the AI-DLC and the
resources configured with that.
So with that, I'm gonna
switch to my agent.
And we're gonna select that one
and that's gonna give us the
agent that we're gonna use
to actually build out the game.
So.
- [Derek] Yep, thanks Kiran and, you know,
just to emphasize,
this is a relatively
simple thing to configure,
but by pulling in those resource files,
we're gonna dramatically alter
the behavior of the agent,
as you'll see in a minute here,
from what we would get by default.
And so there's a lot
of power under the hood
that we can have here, by
developing custom workflows,
specific ways that we
want the agent to work.
And that's something that
teams can work together on
and refine over time.
And we're seeing libraries of
these emerge within customers,
as the different teams kind of
maybe build their own repo internally,
just to refine these files,
get these better and better over time.
So there's a lot that you can do here
by just loading in a few
context files and a few tools.
So we're gonna spend the rest
of the time here building,
and the goal here is to build
a game called Flappy Kiro,
by the end of the session.
We'll see how it goes, it's live,
so we have some backup
plans in case things,
we have some kind of problem,
but I'll try not to jinx us here.
Flappy Kiro is a game where Kiro the,
or I think his name is
Ghostie actually, we decided.
- Yeah, Flappy Ghostie.
- Okay.
So Ghostie is going to
be able to scroll through
a side scrolling game, and
when we push space bar,
he'll flap up in the air.
When we let go of the
space bar he'll drop down.
And he's gotta avoid
obstacles and get a score.
The point here is less about
the implementation details
that we pick, or what language,
or hopefully the game actually works,
and whether it's good or not.
What we really want to do
is focus on the workflow,
and focus on how we can use
AI from the very beginning
to help us get our
requirements and our design,
and our thinking about
our plan and our testing
and everything that we need to do,
in order to build
production grade software.
So while we're not building
production grade software today,
and we're gonna sort of speed
through some of the steps,
I hope that you walk away today
maybe inspired a little bit
to go try some of these
techniques yourselves,
and try doing an end-to-end, you know,
task or story from your
backlog, using this process
and using AI from the very
beginning of your project.
So anything else I should do
to tee up Flappy Kiro here?
I think it's a pretty straightforward game
and we'll get into some
of the details here.
- [Kiran] Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna try and get it to work on here
as well as on mobile phone.
So we'll switch to the development tools
and see if it works on a mobile.
But I'll try and get it to work first
and then we'll go from there.
- [Derek] All right,
let's see how we get on.
- Okay.
- Let's see if this works.
Oh great.
- Yeah, it did.
Okay, so to build this, we're
gonna just use one prompt.
So this is the prompt I'm gonna use.
I'm gonna walk, spend a little
bit of time going through it.
So the goal is not to do
any prompt engineering
or have any secret sauce baked into this.
We're gonna have one clear prompt
and then we're gonna go
through the AI-DLC process,
which has been shortened to
fit into the session today.
So the first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna use,
Derek mentioned in the presentation,
a lot of the LLM's trained, you know,
latent knowledge that it's
got when it was trained.
So a lot of this it's aware of,
and it can actually make a lot
of assumptions based on this,
but we still want to guide
it with proper requirements,
business requirements, you
know, functional requirements,
non-functional requirements,
and then implementation plans.
So the first thing is,
I'm gonna say I wanna
build a browser based game
called Flappy Kiro, for a
live demo at AWS re:Invent.
We're gonna follow the AI-DLC
methodology and workflow
and we're gonna ask the LLM
to ask us clarifying questions
so that it can then provide
the answers as inputs
for each phase.
I want to show you some Mermaid diagrams
so when it actually builds
out the file structure
and the implementation plan,
you can see what that looks like.
And if you look in the IDE,
it actually gives you a
really good visual of that.
Because we're doing this in the CLI,
I'm just gonna use a Mermaid
webpage that we've got,
and we'll show you all
the architecture diagrams
that it does.
So we've streamlined the process,
obviously to fit into the session today.
When we run this with our customers,
it's usually a one-day
workshop, sometimes two.
But we're gonna get this
to work in 45 minutes.
And then we're gonna maintain
interactive questions and
answering throughout the process.
And we wanna save the files
in the working directory
so it doesn't put it everywhere.
So I'm being quite specific with it,
but we still have to, we're still gonna do
quite a bit of guidance and give it themes
and everything like that.
- [Audience Member] Are
you taking questions
as you go or not?
- [Derek] The question was,
are we using questions as you go?
- [Audience Member] Are you
gonna take questions or not?
- [Derek] Take questions as we go.
I think while the agent is thinking,
I think we'll have some time.
Yeah.
- [Kiran] Especially
through the build phase,
it takes a good five, seven minutes.
- Yeah.
- So we can
take some time then.
Okay.
So we're gonna go ahead and execute this,
and fingers crossed.
So the first stage is gonna
be the analysis phase,
or we're gonna gather
all the requirements.
In the real world,
this will be your business
requirements that you might have
within your organization.
Give this agent permission to do that.
So it'll be things like, you know,
what sort of third-party
systems do you need to use,
what sort of logging or anything like that
that you might have,
if you have any security
postures that you need to follow,
things like that.
That will be part of your
business requirements.
So here we go, it's gone and created a,
and I will make this bigger.
And if anyone has any suggestions
we can take them as well,
as we go through this,
otherwise it'll just be me
filling these out as we go along.
And as Derek mentioned,
each time we run this,
we get a slightly different result,
so it's not always the same.
The questions do come
back a bit different.
But when you use the full
AI-DLC, you get very specific
and then you tend to get
the correct response.
- [Derek] Just to
elaborate, if I can, Kiran.
- [Kiran] Yeah.
- [Derek] I think what we find
is that the frontier models,
the LLMs, they're eager to please, right?
And so if we're vibe coding,
often the model will sort of
take what you've asked it to
do and start running with it,
and start building stuff,
rather than sort of stepping
back and thinking critically,
like, you know, maybe a senior
engineer might step back
and say, "Hey, before we build this,
I've got like 15 questions about,
what did you think about security?
Did you think about this?"
You know, "What about
this edge case, right?"
And that's kind of the conversation
that we want to be having.
And so really what we've got
loaded into the context here
is a lot of specific instructions saying,
"Hey, don't skip any of these steps."
If we don't know the answer yet,
let's get the answer
before we keep moving.
And so the first step here
where we've told Kiro,
"Hey, I wanna build this thing."
Is, okay, I've got a bunch of questions,
please answer those for
me before we continue.
So we'll fill those out here,
but it should keep asking
us until it's clear.
- [Kiran] Yeah, exactly, yeah.
And these questions are predefined ones.
This isn't like a final list.
If you have something
when you're doing this
for an enterprise app,
you can go and actually
put those in there.
So if there's a question
you feel that your,
hasn't, you know, met
your organization's needs,
that's something that you
can just insert in there too.
It doesn't have to be, it won't freak out.
And I'll show you an example of that.
So the way I answer these questions,
I'm supposed to fill them in down here.
I'm just gonna say yes no,
and then for this one I'll fill
them out all then down here
for question two, and we'll
go through it like that
and see how the agent deals with that.
So for the first question,
we want it to continuously
fly and, or it says,
or only when clicking, when
pressing the space bar.
So I'll say, yeah.
Press, I'll just say a button.
Press a button to fly.
And then for the easy,
difficult, easy, medium or hard,
I'm gonna say, easy has larger, yeah,
I could say larger obstacle gaps.
Getting harder as the game progresses.
There we go.
And should the game
speed increase over time,
I'll just give that a flat yes.
This takes quite a bit of time
when you're building
out an enterprise app,
but hopefully we'll get
through this quite quickly.
So then we get to the
visual styles of this too.
So what I wanna do is, I'll
change this a little bit.
We're gonna use say maybe
some of the AWS colors.
I'll go with orange and black.
I'll go with a Halloween theme,
it was recently Halloween.
And say Las Vegas theme as well.
Let's see how it deals with that.
A lot of typos there.
Okay, do you want the Kiro character
to be a simple shape,
sprite, or custom design?
So Kiro is a ghost, so we
wanna use a, it's like purple,
purple ghost character.
Should the obstacles be
classic, you know, the classic,
obviously it's got that latent knowledge,
it knows exactly what that game is.
So let's go with AWS-themed,
and it's got that from
the prompt that we did
saying that we're doing an
AWS re:Invent presentation.
And then we wanna say use say AI
and coding services from AWS.
There we go.
And then scoring and leaderboard.
What kind of scoring
features would you like?
I'll take suggestions, if
you wanna shout 'em out,
otherwise I'll just fill these in.
So we'll, so simple score,
or do you want to use a leaderboard?
So we'll just go with simple for now.
And then here we're just
gonna use local storage,
'cause we don't have anything
like that configured.
And then in the real world,
obviously it's looking for,
you know, if you're using an API gateway,
you can use something like CloudFront.
If you want this game
to be globally available
closer to your customers
in different regions.
That's something you'd specify over here.
For the purposes of this,
we're gonna do this.
We'll say yes to that.
And then how long do you want it to be?
I'll just go one to two
minutes and say yes to that.
And on a mobile phone.
Test that towards the end.
- [Derek] I like the ambition level here.
- [Kiran] Yeah!
- [Derek] You're adding a lot of features.
- [Kiran] HTML and Java.
Let's use those two for
the purpose of this.
Single file, I think
we'll use multiple files,
'cause I wanna have
proper structure for this.
So in case we need to go
back and change something,
or we want to document any of
these decisions and come back
and ask why we did that,
it's all nicely documented.
So I'll go with multiple files for.
- [Audience Member]
You've got a typo of HTML.
- [Kiran] Yeah, yeah.
Good catch.
It's pretty good at picking
up all my bad typos, so.
(indistinct)
Yeah.
I'll see how it deals with
that one, I'll leave it alone.
Any AWS services we wanna showcase?
Anything, should we do that, should we do,
I don't think it knows about Kiro yet.
Mind you, it's got that
MCP survey to go and fetch,
fetch, things like that.
- [Derek] I'm a proud WorkMail
user, but it's probably not.
- [Kiran] WorkMail.
So that's-
- Probably not
appropriate here.
- Amplify.
- Sorry?
- Amplify?
- Amplify.
Okay.
- We can do that.
Let's see what it does there,
and I'll put maybe Bedrock,
since it's gonna be running on that.
Okay.
Let's try those and then
start screen instructions.
So we say, yes with.
- [Derek] I would just suggest, Kiran,
for Amplify and Bedrock,
maybe just make a note that
we need a way to test locally.
- [Kiran] Okay.
- [Derek] Since we're not gonna have time
to deploy to an AWS environment, so.
- [Kiran] Yeah.
- Cool.
- Okay.
Restart button.
Just say yes and then we'll
move on to the next phase.
Mobile support.
Sorry, support for
mobile browsers I think.
And then maybe wanna use
maybe Chrome and Firefox.
I think those are the two
commonly most used ones.
Chrome and Firefox.
Okay, great.
And that's it.
So we'll go ahead and save that.
Close that up and then we can say done.
And again, I'm still
using that single prompt
and it should now go
ahead, read those answers,
and come back and start
building out the design phase.
And the whole purpose of this is
we're bringing the agent and the LLM
into the decision-making process.
So yeah, saving, sorry about that.
Saving a lot of time.
- [Derek] And just to note
that we were just doing
a lot of what I would call
classic product manager work
and less software development.
But it's very important obviously,
and one thing that we're finding is that
getting together cross-functional teams
that maybe might not work
together next to each other
day by day, but getting
the product managers
and the stakeholders along
with the software developers,
maybe QA, Ops, right?
Getting that cross-functional team
that's gonna be
responsible for this thing,
sometimes physically together,
or at least on the same call,
and working together on
answering these questions,
can help teams get this right upfront
and skip a lot of back and forth
that we might traditionally do,
where we need to email or
cut a ticket to someone
to find out.
And so if we're able to do
this collaboratively upfront,
we can dramatically cut down
on the time needed for us
to get all of this right.
And the agent in this
case is really our helper
to make sure that we're
documenting it properly.
- [Kiran] Yeah.
Yeah, thanks.
So now we're moving on from what to build
and now we're going on to
how we're actually gonna
go ahead and build that.
So it's taken some of the
suggestions of SageMaker, Amplify,
saw that there, and Bedrock,
and now it's gonna come through
and ask us, you know, "How
are we gonna do these?"
And if you think about,
these are now your more,
your technical requirements.
We've defined the business
requirements in the first phase.
We're moving on to more of
the technical stuff right now.
So earlier on in here, it's given us,
using that agent that we configured.
We told it to have the Mermaid MCP server.
It's gone in and actually built out
some Mermaid diagrams for us.
So I'll show you what that looks like.
Hopefully that looks good on the screen.
There we go.
So it's actually already
documented and drawn out
what it thinks this is gonna look like.
And do you remember that one prompt?
Did you want everything in a single file
or do you want it split up?
And it's gone ahead and
split that up for us as well,
with specific files for different things.
So we have JavaScript
files and HTML files,
so you can go in and make changes later.
So this is really useful
for things like that too.
So just, sorry.
I'll come back there.
Okay, and then if we look over here,
so let's have a look at this one here too.
It shows you the different components
that we've got over here.
Sorry, I left my mouse at home.
Would've been a bit easier with that.
There we go.
So it's showing you the
different, you know,
the different layers it's gonna build out
and how that's gonna look.
Does that look good on the screen?
Go a bit bigger.
So we found this really, really useful.
Our customers have told us that, you know,
this saves a lot of time
with the documentation and,
you know, and how that's gonna look.
And they can use that
for all their different
change controls and, you know,
when they submitted tickets
to have this all built out.
So we're getting all of that.
Remember I said local storage only.
We're not gonna deploy
that to anything else.
So that's that over there.
We already talked about how
we're gonna do the obstacles,
it's gone and filled all
that in, the scoring.
I said do that as we pass the obstacles,
and the difficulty controller,
from the easy, medium and hard.
So all of that's all in there already.
Okay, so let's go back
in and fill out that,
fill out the rest of that for
the technical requirements.
Okay, so the first question it's got is,
which AI coding services
should appear as obstacles?
So I'm just gonna say, use
all and use them randomly.
How should the difficulty levels differ?
Now I've found, when I've
been building this out,
testing this, is it usually,
the gravity is way too strong.
So the bird just falls like a stone,
no matter how quickly
I press the space bar.
And the gaps are way too short,
so I can never get past the
first couple of hurdles.
So I might go in here
from my previous knowledge
and tell it to be a little
bit better with that.
So I'll say start slower,
larger gaps, and less gravity.
And then I wanna use it to
use 60 frames per second.
And then, now we've got the visuals.
So shall I generate a simple CSS canvas,
or do we have any image assets?
I start with a normal simple CSS canvas,
but then you can go back in,
download specific assets,
or any audio images that
you've got for the game,
and you can put that in.
But it does a pretty
good job of filling the,
just, you know, coming
up with stuff itself.
So we'll go with CSS.
And then ghost animation,
do you want a static,
bobbing, flapping wings?
Let's animate the ghost
when it's flying.
Let's use official AWS icons.
I don't think it's gonna
be able to do that,
unless we actually give it to them,
but it's gonna try and draw them up
and typically it uses emojis
or something like that too.
Sound effects.
I'll just say use all suggested effects,
just with interests of time.
Here we go.
And then this question here,
the Bedrock integration.
How should Amazon Bedrock be integrated?
Dynamically, AI-powered,
difficulty adjustments, generate.
What do you think?
This is quite interesting.
- [Derek] I think those are all future-
- [Kiran] Yeah.
- enhancements, right?
- Yeah.
- [Derek] So it probably
doesn't matter for this demo.
- [Kiran] Yeah.
And then here's the file
structure that it's gonna go ahead
and create for you.
So instead of creating that one big file,
you saw that diagram,
it's gonna go ahead and
break these down for you
in the different files
that you're gonna use.
And that means you can come back in
and put in your own
images and your own sounds
when you want it to do so.
I'll just say.
Okay.
And then let me just hit that.
- [Derek] So again,
we're almost kind of like
speed running through
these steps.
- Yeah.
- [Derek] And almost vibe
coding in a way, right,
by not engaging more here and
doing a much richer discussion
in the interest of time.
But, you know, again, I
think you can imagine,
this is where I, in my opinion,
the interesting work is gonna happen
is around these decisions
that we're making
around technology selection,
and what should we do first
and what can, you know,
what's a P0 versus a P1 feature and
what's our architecture gonna look like?
You know, this is where we, as humans,
should be spending our time.
And if we get this right up front,
the actual implementation
phase is almost the easy part,
hopefully, because we've already done
all of this hard work upfront.
And so if you're not already,
I would encourage you,
if you try out AI-DLC, you know,
spend a good amount of time
upfront in these phases.
Get this as refined as you can.
And then see how the implementation
step works out for you.
- [Audience Member] How
did you get to this phases
just by saying I wanted AI-DLC?
- [Derek] Yeah, so we'll link
at the end to the GitHub repo,
but our teams have put
a good amount of work
over the last few months,
again working with lots
of different customers
to refine this.
We're using conditional context loading
because we have a finite
amount of context window space.
There's an initial context
file that we loaded
that kind of kicks off things
with the agent and tells it,
"Hey, you're using this workflow,
you're gonna use these
various specific steps."
And then depending on what you're doing,
if you're doing greenfield
or if you're extending
an existing application,
if you wanna do microservices,
there's a bunch of decision
trees that it'll make
and say, oh we're using,
we're going to extend
the legacy application.
It'll actually load in
additional instruction sets
to make sure that we're doing
things in an orderly way.
So there's a lot behind the scenes here
that's getting loaded in as needed.
- [Audience Member] Is that
markdown files referenced
in the agent?
- [Derek] Yep, yep.
There's just the one markdown
file is the entry point
and it has instructions that says
conditionally load these other files,
depending on what you're doing.
We found that approach works
well to keep the context window
not too busy.
- [Kiran] Yeah, and then to your point,
the other thing you can do is
you can have different agents
for different phases of
your development as well.
So, you know, if you're
doing front end development,
backend development, you
can have different agents
with different MCP servers,
different resources.
And that way you can do,
and they can just switch
between those agents
as easily as I showed you there.
And, yeah.
And that way that's a good way
of getting your project done
without loading everything up.
So, yeah.
Okay, so now this is
the part where we move
to the actual implementation phase.
Still haven't written any
code yet, but now we're gonna,
you know, this thing, you can
start having it cut, you know,
Jira tickets for you,
and you can have your
junior developers go ahead
and run this, based on
the architecture diagrams
that your senior developers
or Kiro has built for you.
So again, we are just gonna
go through these real quick
and see what we can get from all of it.
So approved to implement, yes,
we're just gonna go through
the resolution size, link
all the modules together.
And then here if you
have any specific styling
that your organization might
use, this is a, you know,
a good place where you can do that
if you're building an enterprise app.
So that's something you
can do there as well.
And if there's anything, you know,
you'd be sitting with different
teams across your business
going through all of this and figuring out
is this the right thing to do
if it's not captured in here.
You can obviously add it in there
and change some of those files as well.
And we'll go through that as well.
Yeah.
So we are gonna use JavaScript and HTML,
I think we decided that was
gonna be the best thing,
so we're just gonna go ahead with that.
It's just asking for
that final verification
before we do anything.
- [Audience Member] Are there
any Jira MCPs or integrations?
- [Derek] Yep.
There is a Jira MCP,
and so I was just thinking
the same thing, like,
once you get to this
step, in the real world,
each of these might be more
complicated and take more time.
So you can imagine each
of these becoming a story
that goes onto the Jira board
and gets pulled down for sure.
And that could be as simple
as us taking this file
and saying, hey, go create
Jira stories for each of these.
- Yeah.
- [Kiran] I'll be
honest, this is different
from the other ones that I've done before.
Normally it's another bunch of questions,
but here it's just basically saying,
you've provided me enough,
and just give me the
verification for that.
So just answering, yes.
We'll have a look at this
diagram that it's given us.
This should be the implementation diagram.
It didn't grab everything
there, for some reason.
I thought I had it all.
Yeah, I did.
Didn't like that.
Try it once more.
- [Derek] I suggest, Kiran,
in the interest of time,
that we-
- Yeah, we are
running short, okay.
- Keep going.
- [Kiran] Okay, and you can
see when it gets to this part,
the agent's already thinking about
how it's gonna generate the testing.
So it's gonna have functional testing
and any sort of unit testing
and stuff you might
wanna do for your code.
It'll generate that in the next phase too.
But it's already thinking ahead,
how am I gonna test this end to end?
You know, this is quite a, you know,
obviously the different, I've
said to it, use, you know,
Firefox and Chrome because
it's gonna go on mobile phones.
It figured that some people
are gonna have iPhones
and it's put Safari in there
as well, which is great.
Chrome mobile, Chrome desktop.
So yeah, so we'll go ahead and save that.
And.
Okay, now it's gonna go ahead and create
all the different files for us,
to actually build the project up.
And there we go, it's gonna
create the assets file,
the CSS files, the JavaScript files,
and hopefully we'll get a working game.
So this is where it takes a few minutes,
five or seven minutes if it works, so.
- [Derek] And we spend a
lot of time on requirements,
design, technology
selection, not coding, right?
We've got 16 minutes left in the hour.
We'll see how we get on.
But again, this is sort of the,
almost the opposite of vibe
coding and starting with build.
And this was really the thing
that we wanted to impart is,
it's time well spent doing this upfront.
AI-DLC is one framework.
Again, there are other approaches.
You could build something yourself,
you might consider forking what we've got,
if you're interested.
In fact, send us a merge request
if you find a way to
improve on the process.
But the idea is to have a
plan going into the process.
- Question.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] So I'm
working in a similar way,
similar process, but
my struggle with that,
it's always very tedious.
We plan everything, all the details.
Some of the questions we have seen
seem irrelevant at this point in time.
You don't really care.
And then when it starts
building, you realize,
oh wait a second,
actually I wanna change my
mind and change (indistinct).
And so it's very difficult to go back
because you're forcing
(indistinct) yourself
with this linear process.
- Yeah.
- Do you have any experience
with that?
Looking for like iterative development.
Like build a very simple
first version or whatever
and then un-extend it when I've seen it?
- [Derek] Yeah.
To summarize the question.
This process, it's been linear, right,
where we do all these steps in order.
And in reality, in real life,
we might start implementing
phase one and say,
"Actually I changed my mind,
I wanna tweak the requirements."
I think you certainly can go back to
one of the previous stages,
edit the requirements,
and then ask the tool to
update the design, for example.
I don't think I have any
real shortcuts for that.
I think we've gotta pay
the price at some point.
If we wanna change the requirements,
we're gonna have to go
through those steps again.
I think that the,
by getting the right
people in the room upfront,
we can hopefully minimize
that back and forth
in terms of what the
requirements should be.
In terms of iterating on the
design and the implementation,
one of the benefits is, we
can move pretty quickly here.
And so the iteration
step, whereas, you know,
in previous lives that
might be like a whole sprint
that we just used to build something
and we've gotta start over again.
We could potentially make that cycle time
quite a bit shorter.
But I don't have a way around, you know,
needing to go back and-
- [Audience Member] No,
no, it's fine to go back.
It's more like, like the
context is blown out, et cetera,
I don't wanna go back,
so I'd rather like
build the like MCP thing
of this game, document what
you did, then I'll look at it,
change my mind and then like, (indistinct)
I have specified so far, and
change the specification again
so it's like a cycle process.
- Yeah.
- You start with fresh context
just with the key
learnings from cycle one,
going into cycle two with
more space in the context
and starting from there.
- [Derek] So the, just
to repeat the question,
the question is about being
able to save the context
and go back and edit it later,
and be able to iterate based
on what we've learned so far.
So we're writing all
of the design decisions
into markdown files.
All of the Q&A and all of the descriptions
of the requirements and design and such.
There's also an audit log that
automatically gets written
of all the questions and
decisions that were made.
One thing that we've seen is
just taking all of these files
and attaching them back
into the Jira tickets.
And so anybody that wants
to go back and understand
why did we make this
decision, or, you know,
what was used as input here,
we can go back and reproduce it.
We've also seen, you know, the
context window can get full,
and so in between each of these steps,
we've actually cleared the context
and then started fresh again.
And that kind of proves to ourselves
that everything that's needed
to reproduce what we've got
is stored in these markdown files,
- [Audience Member] Basically
clear everything else,
just signal what's in the files?
- [Derek] Yep, and that's
in our custom agent, yep.
And then, so in theory, we
should be able to go back
to any step at any time, using
one of these as artifacts,
make a tweak and move forward from there.
- [Audience Member] How is this different
from using the Kiro IDE?
Because I use it and it
follows very similar phases
where like I really have
the design requirements
and tasks, and here you have analysis,
design and implementation.
Do you think one is more
powerful than the other?
Or depending, like if we, you
did your own customer agent,
so it's like in that case
would this be more powerful
than the spec on IDE?
- [Derek] The question was,
which is sort of the better approach.
Kiro IDE has spec-driven development.
We're doing this AI-DLC
workflow in the CLI.
They have similar bits of functionality.
We're moving fast in all of this.
The IDE, I would say,
spec-driven development,
is less customizable at this point, right?
You're gonna kinda get what you get.
And for a lot of customers,
they really like it and they're using it.
This is much more configurable.
The AI-DLC approach, or
an approach like this,
gives you the ability
to tailor this process
with your development teams over time,
and make it as granular and
specific, always do it this way,
don't do it that way, as you want.
In return, the process is
more complicated, right?
It's gonna take more time.
We're skipping a bunch of steps.
If we were going through the full thing
and we hadn't told it
we were doing a demo,
it would be documenting
tons of user stories
and asking what personas
should we be doing?
And so it'll go a lot deeper than this.
And so I would suggest that
maybe as a starting point,
or for features that
are a little bit more,
I don't wanna say straightforward.
I would say Kiro IDE is
a good starting point.
But if you're looking for
more ability to customize,
or the ability to get a few levels deeper
into the requirements,
I would suggest that
this is a good approach.
But I also think that you'll see over time
we'll continue to build out
that spec-driven workflow
in the IDE, and that'll get
more and more features as well.
How are we doing, Kiran?
- [Kiran] It built actually quite quickly.
There was no contention
on Bedrock, I think.
I think we're good there.
So, yeah.
- We'll have to see
if it works.
- Yeah, well let's,
yeah, so it did build us the
implementation plan and then,
let me close that down and
bring up the other one.
So yeah, we got all, you know,
all the coding was complete.
You get a full report of
everything that was done,
how much code was written,
all the features that were implemented,
the stuff that we walked
through in the beginning.
And yeah, it tells you how to test it
and it also gives you a
whole testing plan as well.
This is quite a basic one obviously,
but you can obviously
imagine what it'll produce
when you do a proper document.
So yeah, with that,
let's see what happens.
So I think it's just
this file here we can go.
So there we go.
We got the start screen.
Looks all right so far.
This is the worst part!
Easy.
There we go.
Actually it wasn't too bad.
Okay.
- Nice.
- [Kiran] The Bedrock
thing wasn't as impressive
as I thought.
- [Derek] I think that's a Pac-Man ghost.
- [Kiran] Yeah, yeah.
It doesn't actually look in there, but,
it's picking up scores and,
I don't know if there's any sound on here.
There's no sound.
- I think we said no sound.
- [Kiran] Yeah, they said no sound.
But there should have been,
I can unplug my mic in a sec.
(indistinct)
- [Derek] Oh no, I mean
when we set up the stage
we said no sound.
That was our mistake.
- [Kiran] That's actually
better than I thought.
- Yeah.
- A lot of them
just didn't work, it
just sunk like a stone.
But, yeah.
- Cool, nice.
We've got eight minutes.
Happy to take more
questions and discussion
about the process.
Also happy to take modification
requests to the game,
if we wanna try that.
- Yeah.
(indistinct)
Yes.
- [Derek] Yes, I will put
that up right at the end here.
I'll do some crowd work here.
- [Audience Member] So our
team recently did a test
where we went like full Kiro,
and just had it kind of go
crazy and make a whole web app.
My issue with it was that a
lot of it was like inaccessible
and like had like,
there was like window to open
things and things like that.
And I'm just wondering what
recommendations you have.
Like is it like adding a
frontend MCP to the front of it?
Like what would you
recommend to help make sure
it kind of followed WCAG guidelines.
- [Derek] So you're
talking about accessibility
like A11, like?
- Yeah.
- [Derek] Okay.
How specific were you at the beginning
about your accessibility requirements,
and what was must have, nice to have?
- [Audience Member] I'm not
sure, I had delegated the-
- [Derek] Got it, got it!
So I think that would be my answer, right?
The more time we spend up front, again,
if this is a web app,
talking to the UX folks,
the stakeholders, the product managers,
getting really into the weeds on
what are the non-negotiables
for accessibility.
And if we can get all of that,
you know, decided upfront,
and documented into one
of these markdown files,
I would expect that we
would get, you know,
better results there.
- [Audience Member] Is
there a way to, like,
there's like WCAG guidelines.
Like is there a way to
like more easily integrate
that even just as a base,
'cause there's like
actual specs and whatnot.
- Yep.
- Is there a way
to do that?
- [Derek] So, you know, one thing,
as you're developing your, you know,
version of this for your teams,
again, you could imagine
having a repo of these
context files and a custom
agent that you publish
for the teams and say,
"Hey, use this when you're
building a web app."
And in that custom agent in
the context you could say,
the following are kind
of company standards
for accessibilities like,
thou shall make sure that
you hit these versions of,
or these WCAG requirements.
The model is gonna have a
pretty good understanding
of those requirements baked
into its latent knowledge.
But if you wanted to really
make sure that you nailed it,
you could say, hey, in fact,
I'm guessing I would be
willing to wager that there's a
WCAG MCP server where you can go,
where you can go and grab the actual spec.
So that would come at
the cost of more context,
that you'd have to load.
But you could, I could imagine saying,
"Hey, as part of our verification,
I want you to make sure that
you've built all of this in."
And actually go test it.
So I think you get as sophisticated
as you wanted to, and,
you know, I would suggest
starting by adding that up front
into the context and
having it build that in.
- Okay.
- Yeah, thanks.
I have one over here.
There you go.
- [Audience Member] I work as a manager
of a developer experience
team in our company,
and we have like 300 engineers as a whole.
And one of the difficulties
that we have is like
how we standardize the AI knowledge.
'Cause people like to use Kiro,
some of those like to use
Cursor, Cloud Code, whatever.
And when I look at
these, it's kind of like
a little bit more concentrating on Kiro,
or like how is the difference
with like Agents.md,
for example, that's kind
of like a standardization
independent of the tools.
Like that's a little bit
of my question here is like
how can make that reusable,
of the two that developer is choosing.
So probably it'll make easier to adopt.
- [Derek] Yeah.
So we're seeing a lot of
innovation in all of the tools
in this space.
So things are moving fast.
Agents.md seems to be
a defacto standard that's emerging.
That's good.
The different tools have
different ways for specifying,
you know, this concept of custom agents.
This workflow, the AI-DLC,
is just a bunch of markdown files.
So, you know, it would work
fine in Cloud Code or Cursor,
what have you.
So this isn't meant to be
specifically tied to Kiro.
We think that Kiro is a great
platform for doing this,
but we're not trying
to sort of lock it down
to one particular tool.
But ideally you're able to
bundle together the AI-DLC
or the context files that you have,
that you wanna steer the
behavior of the model,
as well as your list of
MCP servers together,
and have a way to publish that out
to other folks in your organization.
So with Kiro CLI, that's just a JSON file.
And so all that could be
is an internal repository
where you say, "Hey, if
you're building web apps,
use this custom agent.
If you're extending this old
legacy app, go use this agent."
And that combined kind
of collective wisdom
of how to operate around
those different domains
is baked into those agents.
Yeah.
I think I saw one more.
Oh, come over to you next.
- [Audience Member] First of all,
thank you for that great presentation.
When you have these different
stages in the AI-DLC
and in the agent definition
there was this line model
that was null.
So you leave the selection
of the model to use
to the automatic,
or would you suggest
using different models
for different tasks and
stages in the AI-DLC?
- [Derek] Yep.
Thanks for the question.
So by default, we now
have an auto mode in Kiro,
and that's gonna allow
us to select the model
and give you a discount
in terms of credits.
And our goal with the engineering team,
and they're spending a
lot of energy on this,
is making that auto mode work
great so that you, as a user,
would never have a reason
to change the model.
'Cause you're very happy with the outcome.
So that would be our recommendation
is start with the auto mode.
Hopefully you get great.
If you're not sure you're getting great
and you wanna say no, I
definitely want Sonnet 4.5
or whatever the latest
model of the day is,
you could switch to that
and see if you get different results.
But our hope and our expectation is that
you can start with just
not defining the model,
use the default auto mode.
Yep.
I'm gonna take one more here
and I know we're just wrapping up on time.
- [Audience Member] So first of all,
thank you so much for the
presentation, the demo,
and I just tried the Kiro
app and also the CLI as well.
They both work really
fast, I really like it.
- Great!
- Yeah.
I like the (indistinct).
But the things are, you know,
I know a lot of independent developers.
They try so many like AI coding
agent, Cursor, Cloud Code.
So actually I want to get more insight
that how to differentiation
from Kiro and those,
another coding agent.
For example, are we going to
have more integration on AWS
or, you know, do some more, you know,
integration work on
enterprise integration.
- [Derek] Yeah, thank you.
We're right at time, but I'll say,
in terms of differentiation,
we want Kiro to be a great product,
regardless of where you're developing,
even if it's not on AWS.
And so our intention is to just focus on
a great developer experience.
Of course we want it to be
really good at AWS as well.
So that's the thinking.
You know, differentiators,
there's a lot of smart folks
that are building other
cool tools in this space.
I think it's a good time for end users,
because that competition is having folks
kind of leapfrog each
other in capabilities.
I expect that's gonna continue to happen.
I'd say one nice thing about
Kiro is, when you subscribe,
you have access to both
the CLI and the IDE
for one subscription.
And we see a lot of folks that
like to switch back and forth
between those modes, or
maybe even use both at once.
So I think that's a nice thing.
I would say the spec-driven
development in the IDE,
which we didn't look at today,
but we've heard a lot of great feedback
that that's a good way for developers
to sort of structure their approach.
So I would encourage you,
if you haven't, to try both.
Try the spec-driven workflow in Kiro IDE.
Try the AI-DLC, which
is a bit more in depth,
and see which one suits you the best.
So, very brief answer to your question,
but I know we're right at time so.
- [Audience Member] Okay, thank you.
- [Derek] All right.
Thank you all, thanks, Kiran.